[Applaudissements]
on est en direct charlize theron je suis
sortie de l'émission parce que le matin
j'avais dit un truc
j'avais dit aux équipes qui avaient dit
franchement charlize theron vient les
mecs il faut lui faire le chocolat le
chocolat grippe a je voulais lui faire
le chocolat c'est mes équipes m'ont dit
tu peux vraiment là ces incidents
diplomatiques
je suis sortie de l'émission livré
n'aurions maître chocolatier le cdh on
nous avait dit je vais vous dire
pourquoi j'aurais fait ça pour quoi
charlize theron ja considéreraient plus
que les chroniqueurs opus qui est notre
invité - charlize theron jamais au même
plan que les autres
donc voilà c'est pas parce que c'est aux
soi-disant une grande star américaine
que je vais pas là chocolatier tu as là
moi j'étais à bien tous les invités
alors mais l'effervescence temps passe
on m'a pas vous chocolatées à vous
pouvez venir à cette émission retourne
au procès
[Applaudissements]
des invités pourquoi il s'en est pris
tout ça voilà
eh ben je vous dis et bat donc voilà la
prochaine si quelques amis la famille
mpokora elle s'est quand même une limite
est particulière mais est donc pour moi
ils sont tous logés à la même enseigne
ces chocolats pour tout le monde et
l'égalitarisme et puis même en coulisses
ont apparemment il est 23 ans cette
antenne on peut tout dévoiler même en
coulisses elle m'a eu un comportement
non mais ouais désagréable avec les
preneurs de les techniciens c'est vrai
désarroi l'avait mal par le technicien
cette fois c'est le chocolat sa réussite
et ron est leur parler mal elle voulait
même pas qui la touche de toucher
quelqu'un tombe à leur micro le pauvre
technique jacques ce qui va faire et à
ma fille voulait qu'ils nous mettent le
micro mais comme ça il aux violences
genou à mon frère l'a donc à géographie
variable humour âge et envieux la robe
cela pas être facile de mettre un micro
s'est passé de grave
[Applaudissements]